[Music]
one of the most satisfying moments in
anime is when a character utterly
destroys everyone in the room or
disgustingly front their overwhelming
power on their opponent whether it's a
moment of pure disrespect or a
well-deserved Showcase of strength it's
the highlight of the show in this video
I've gathered 20 anime moments that are
all about flexing on their opponent and
you're not going to want to miss it we
kick things off with one of the coldest
hand-to-hand fights ever witnessed in
the
outcast Oya being chased and with no
escape from the M Outcast had no choice
but to confront them head on and you
know what it might just be the best
decision ever because what follows is a
mind-blowing Showcase of amazing
animation and fight sequences that the
entire show has to offer the
choreography of this fight constantly
brings fresh elements to the table with
each watch the way the cinematography
complements the fight scenes is just
goded here let's have a moment of
silence for those who still haven't
discovered this incredible fight scene
Oya showcases not only his incredible
physical strength but also his
remarkable reflexes he can unleash great
force from various parts of his body
especially his hands sending enemies
flying with a single touch and
effortlessly dodging mult multiple
assaults as if it was just a walk in the
park the animation combined with the
smooth and sick choreography is just Mah
I just wish this level of dedication and
animation had been showcased in the
previous two seasons of the outcast
nevertheless this scene remains one of
the greatest in the show solidifying
what a true Showcase of power looks
like speaking of Godly animation this
scene takes it to a whole new level and
the power flexing doesn't lack
either we brought up the Epic Gilgamesh
versus enkidu many times before in our
videos and for good reason even to this
day it remains an incredibly rewatchable
scene keeping you on the edge of your
seat both enjoyable and exhilarating
it's a reunion between two best friends
an amazing presentation of the power of
divine Spirits enidu was gilgamesh's one
and only match not just in power but in
their Ambitions and initial IDE when
they started their Journey it's
mind-blowing to see how despite their
overwhelming power they laugh it off
displaying not just Machines of
Destruction but the most wholesome
friendship yes they might be destructive
forces but their friendship is one of
the most wholesome things in this whole
story it's the most epic longtime no se
bro I've ever witnessed this power
packed scene where they hold nothing
back is an explosion of eye candy
animation a scene that we're always
going to
remember
when it comes to unleashing the most
creative skills Cipher goinging god mode
is where the magic
happens it's incredible to witness how
her magical abilities evolve throughout
the seasons the creators truly nailed it
on this one the progress in her fighting
style from season 3 to 4 is simply
outstanding there's a massive difference
she's now in total control of her
Magic's EB and flowing combat and her
critical thinking and strategies have
evolved immensely her reflexes to dodge
attacks are sharper than ever making her
an absolute badass what's even crazier
is she did all of that while being
pregnant Cipher's unwavering sense of
justice and Duty combined with immense
mental fortitude shines through in her
actions her uses of the elements as if
they were actual swords or blades
crafting Jewel blades out of Fire and
Ice is definitely some next level stuff
she's redefining what it means to be a
battle mage most Mages typically
One-Shot something but Cipher's battle
scenes have always been my favorite
she's absolutely
[Music]
ruthless this scene in the anime is in
my opinion not just one of the coldest
but also one of the most exciting
moments thus
[Music]
far
freen the cute Mage we've come to know
in each episode has lived through
hundreds of years of experiences and
it's surprising to witness her wield her
power in such a manner it serves as an
example of how much more there is to
discover about her strength to provide
some context here the magic torn in
question serves as a means to determine
who possesses the most magical power the
winner can then enforce their will upon
the loser regardless of the latter's
consent the reason the demon agreed to
such a high stakes gamble is that free
had deliberately concealed her magical
prowess to appear weaker then without
hesitation freen ordered Aura to take
her own life as casually as if it was
just any other ordinary day this act was
chilling to say the least but what's
truly poetic is how Aura with her magic
beheads any Warrior she enslaves to
prevent them from resisting her curse
she's had difficulties with individuals
possessing strong Wills as they can
break free from her commands however
when she attempted to defy Freer Ren's
orders she managed to resist for only a
mere two seconds before tragically
meeting the same fate decapitating
herself this moment showcases the
immense power and authority freen
[Applause]
wields facing off against muscular for
their long awaited rematch deu delivers
a knockout blow to the villain who once
nearly took him
down
what's remarkable though is how he's not
just showcasing raw strength he's now
incorporating various powers from one
for all turning it into an incredible
Powerhouse what I ADW about this scene
is how it portrays deku's growth he
doesn't give into his emotions he fights
with sheer willpower and determination
his increased power and Mastery over his
abilities gives the impression that he's
holding back an incredible example of
the depth of the show's writing as
Endeavor pointed out deu is a true hard
worker and this scene showcases his Rel
lless efforts there's a significant
change in his demeanor too he's quieter
he doesn't even need to scream the names
of his attacks anymore which adds a
chilling touch to the moment finally
seeing these incredible scenes animated
after some time is truly exciting and
just to clarify delivering a punch like
that at 45% power implies he basically
tore the guy's stomach out counting on
regeneration it's terrifying and
absolutely
badass this next entry is certainly
mindblowing and it's an anime that takes
rage mode to a whole new
level it serves as a defining moment of
one's absolute power where wangling
experiences genuine happiness for the
first time only to have it cruy torn
away in an instant the pain and raw rage
in his screams are absolutely gripping
marking the Explosive Start of his
raging Powers as he obliterates the
shadow faction leader this ranks as one
of the best rage moments I've ever
witnessed in an anime and they nailed
this scene but this isn't all about rage
moments but a Showcase of power it's
Crystal Clear that his power surpasses
anyone else we've encountered in this
show it's almost amusing how she thought
she could stand a chance against him
when he holds the power to bring the
world to its knees it's it's quite funny
really when you think about it the way
the music pauses as the time stops then
builds up right as it punch land
bringing her back into the fight is pure
Goosebump material it's important to
know that this isn't even his true power
it's just rage mode if he were to
unleash his full 100% imagine what could
happen the universe might just
collapse this midseason Showdown has
left a lasting cultural imprint on the
community no matter how minor it may be
I
um given the nature of the show where
Sid usually prefers to operate in the
shadows it was only a matter of time
before an explosive show like this took
center stage and when it finally
happened it was undeniably cool it's
been a while since we've witnessed such
hamfisted over-the-top destruction in a
tuny light novel adaptation and it's a
blast to watch our protagonist step up
and save the day once again Sid's
journey to becoming the world's
strongest entity has been nothing short
of eventful and his signature move I am
Atomic is the epitome of his
[Music]
power
animated depiction of made in heaven in
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure is undeniably
[Music]
cool poochie's Incredible speed and the
way he's depicted zooming around are
truly something else it's evident right
from the moment pooi gains control over
Heaven that the odds are stacked against
the protagonists the fact that they
confront did a stand they knew was
nearly unbeatable is just insane one of
the most intriguing aspects of poochie's
character development is how his
fighting style evolves as he acquires
new stands when he had white snake he
was a recluse who operated in the
shadows never revealing himself and
relying on ambushes to catch his enemies
off guard with seam mooon he was able to
stand confidently in the open and level
the playing field finally with made in
heaven he became the pursuer controlling
the environment and keeping constant
pressure on his foes forcing them to be
on the rum it's a fantastic character
Evolution for pooi and it adds a layer
of complexity to the battle the fight
involving maid in heaven is undeniably
the Pinnacle of action in stone ocean
albeit it came at the cost of losing
some incredibly talented fighters in the
series for a brief
moment maa's battle with the five Caray
is undoubtedly one of the best fights in
the Naruto series it's a fight that
continues to impress every time I
revisit
[Music]
it the clash between MAA and the five
caraz is consistently excellent with
standout moments like the utilization of
mokuton clones the episode shines with
its overall presentation especially when
it comes to portraying the gravity and
tension of the battle maa's overwhelming
power and his deep respect for hashirama
add depth to the fight despite facing
five jonian level Shinobi simultaneously
MAA still holds back showcasing his true
extent of his Savage strength MAA UA is
unquestionably one of the series most
formidable characters and witnessing him
effortlessly controlling the most
powerful and respected ninjas in their
respective Villages is a testament to
his unmatched power the battle's
intensity and Ma's unparalleled strength
leave a lasting impression on
viewers
[Music]
what more epic than watching our
socially awkward and wholesome hero mob
slowly turn into a Super Saiyan psychic
mode he's usually a pacifist keeping his
powers in check but when it comes to
protecting his brother he unleashes his
abilities to take down goyama breaking
his own principles sure mob took a
beating at the start but as that psychic
meter went up and his whole vibe shifted
it was a complete 180 once he hit 100%
goyama didn't stand a chance even when
goyama tries his Trump ability the
energy bomb is no match for our favorite
protagonist the moment when mob grabs
goyama by the mouth and crashes down
like a meteor from the sky onto a
building is a treat for my eyes
especially in terms of the animation
it's a satisfying scene where mob shows
his true power and sends a clear message
to Guama never mess with with him and
his brother the sheer badassy of this
moment shakes the entire seasoning City
Middle School gangs making them realize
that mob is the real deal the true white
tea poison this solidifies my opinion as
one of the best scenes in the entire
show in the world of one punch man the
Deep Sea King left a lasting impression
as one of the few villains who stuck
around for more than just one
episode before sca's arrival on the
scene the Deep Sea King red Havoc even
severely injuring sca's disciple Janos
this was perhaps the first time sca's
immense power was visibly demonstrated
in front of an audience after receiving
a rather lackluster punch to the back of
his head from the deep sea king scama
being one punch man delivered a punch so
overwhelmingly powerful that it exploded
the upper half of the creature and
stopped the raid the aftermath of this
encounter is a reminder of saar's
incredible power further cementing his
reputation as a force to be reckoned
with I know this anime was made to be
funny but it's just so endearing when
scy Arma remains humble and unassuming
even going so far as to downplay his
victory lying about his battle with the
seeking for the sake of other Heroes the
heroes association's reluctance to
acknowledge his greatness just adds a
touch of hilarious irony to his
character scarm is undoubtedly a humble
yet remarkable Force in the
[Music]
series moving on this might be the
craziest scene on our list rimu is
usually an easygoing and benevolent
ruler but even he has his Breaking Point
moving on this might be the craziest
scene on our list rimu is usually an
easygoing and benevolent ruler but even
he has his Breaking
Point
when he discovers the massacre of his
people ru's demeanor changes he decides
to unleash his full power obliterating
tens of thousands of human soldiers and
harvesting their souls to become a Demon
Lord rimuru's character is built on
Goodwill aiding strangers and fostering
relationships that being said if you
touch one hair on anyone he cares about
consider yourself dead the one-sided
Massacre left me speechless with a
single spell raru destroys his enemies
yes his aspiration for human and monster
coexistence remains but threatening his
hope and people guarantees an absolute
eradication the moment rimu uttered
megido and the background music got
louder I was covered in Goosebumps the
timing and the musical Arrangement were
impeccable leaving a lasting impression
it's a scene that's both chilling and
immensely
[Music]
satisfying speaking of wiping out your
enemies in a snap of a finger we can't
Overlook the extraordinary power of ir's
old
gown
[Applause]
his ability to summon hundreds of Undead
to fight on his behalf is an incredible
display which was prominently featured
during his encounter with the lizard
tribe while E's Undead summoning proves
invaluable in large scale battles his
summoning of Elemental surpasses that
but what truly captures my attention is
the moment when IR unleashes a spell of
unparalleled might obliterating nearly a
100,000 of the enemy Soldiers the
magnitude of this display was unlike
anything ever witnessed on that
Battlefield leaving both allies and
enemies terrified it's worth noting that
this moment was more traumatizing for
The Winning Side than the kingdoms to
add a fascinating tidbit from the light
novel's volume 10 it's mentioned that
many of the Empire's Knights were so
psychologically scarred by this event
that they would begin shouting all hail
IR all gone upon hearing a goat bleed or
while trembling and weeping in fear this
incident firmly establishes A's
terrifying and unparallel power and
undoubtedly it's one of the standout
moments in the overlord
series imagine having such immense power
that after defeating an opponent you
decide to revive them just for the
amusement of tormenting them all over
again Aros takes this concept to a whole
new level thoroughly humiliating his
opponents
anos VOD is not to be underestimated and
those who do quickly learn the lesson
the hard way just as zepes indu did
during the entrance exams anos is
challenged by The Arrogant demon Noble
and he dispatches him with ease using
nothing more than his own heartbeat and
a single snap but that's not where it
ends Aros revives zepes who remains
unwilling to accept defeat so what does
anos do he takes the humiliation a step
further by repeatedly killing and
Reviving zepes in front of his peers
until he finally surrenders brought to
Tears In Fear this entire scene is just
a full-on Showcase of how terrifying
Aros can be all hail the Demon
King the fight between sukuna and mahura
in jiujitsu kaisen is like a nuclear
explosion in the anime world it's a mind
mindblowing Display of Power that leave
you on the edge of your seat these two
are like walking nukes packing enough
Firepower to level entire cities sua's
cursed techniques are like a series of
devastating blasts while maha's
durability is like an impenetrable
shield and let's not forget the
animation the fight is a visual Feast
with fluid moments Dynamic camera angles
and explosions that will make your
eyeballs pop witnessing sukar's
arrogance on display as he effortlessly
overwhelms an opponent capable of
adapting to any challenge is enthralling
from start to finish the confrontation
is a display of pure destruction
leveling entire blocks of
[Music]
Shibuya for an anime that's been running
for years it's amazing how each season
seems to outdo the previous one and
Luffy's gear five is the epitome of its
[Music]
evolution
we love one piece and not including
Luffy's gear five from this list would
be a crime it is the definition of power
after all of course Luffy's Journey
wasn't a piece of cake it was filled
with many defeats that led to his
immensely satisfying final battle
against kaido Beyond making the anime A
visual treat it also brought to life
Luffy's most powerful transformation the
anime introduced new powerful gear five
attacks not found in the original manga
which makes everything all the more
exciting with Luffy Awakening his devil
fruit it became clear to kaido in the
audience that the gumgum fruit had
incredible potential gear five defies
the usual Trope of an endgame PowerUp in
a showen series with his unconventional
design and fighting styles this form
grants Luffy unparalleled freedom on the
battlefield allowing him to manipulate
the world in his own body in imaginative
ways showcasing the incredible power and
gravity of gear five and Luffy
himself
[Music]
as we approach the end of this list
eron's rumbling can't be
overlooked witnessing the rumbling is
like coming face to face with an
apocalypse a cataclysmic event poised to
end the world there's a NE kind of fear
evoked by this imagery of hopelessness
that spine chilling the image of the
rumbling is tattooed in my mind a
haunting scene of unimaginable power the
emotions displayed rage disappointment
hatred and profound sadness towards
Humanity's intent to destroy him and his
people pulled the trigger the show
doesn't Revel in shock value but quietly
illustrates the reality of Erin's
horrifying actions this devastating
scene isn't meant to entertain but to
highlight the Grim consequences of
eron's well-intentioned yet catastroph
Ric decisions for anyone still holding
out hope for the Redemption of the
anime's hero turned villain this
gut-wrenching genocide is eviden that
such Redemption might not be possible
this stands as a testament to the
unfathomable power eron
[Music]
holds we all know that Ben Maru is
amazing thanks to his second and third
generation pyrokinetic
powers
Benny maru's use of his buddy conro
special attack the Crimson Moon
immediately purifies The Infernal
painting the sky a vivid shade of
crimson the scale of this technique
coupled with Benny maru's Swift recovery
not only speaks volumes about the level
of power required but also solidifies
his reputation as the strongest fire
soldier in my book this scene ranks
amongst the most badass moments in any
anime it truly highlights Benny maru's
awesomeness plus those sound effects
will give me chills fire force is the
epitome of well executed Bas boosted
sound effects while some other anime
attempts at base boost might not hit the
mark fire force delivered a beat drop
harder than my
[Music]
life Muir's strength surpassed many of
his peers even before he acquired a
Demon Slayer
mark
[Music]
during his intense battle against gyoko
the upper moon five demon gyoko revealed
his true form and attempted to trap mui
Jiro in a watery Kon however Muir's
power and determination proved to be
overwhelming he activated his own Demon
Slayer Mark and swiftly struck down
gyoko with a single blow showing
incredible resolve and strength muichiro
was a true 14-year-old progy achieving
the rank of hashid in Just 2 months and
even inventing the seventh form of the
Mist breathing technique the last scene
of him single-handedly defeating upper
moon five in moments is a standout
moment and it's now one of my personal
favorites Migo's extraordinary strength
and quick dispatch of the upper moon
five demon left no crumbs without
allowing even a moment for any backstory
to be
shared
after years of anticipation we finally
got to witness yamamoto's Bankai
animated in what many consider the
series best
[Music]
episode the first division Commander
left fans in a during the sixth episode
of Bleach tybw dominating Twitter Trends
all day upon its release in Japan
Yamamoto Banky is everything you'd
expect from a monstrous Force wielded by
the Go's strongest Captain as a mangara
I'm thrilled with the addition the anime
team made particularly in expanding the
early stages of the fight however the
meat of the battle Faithfully follows
the source material showcasing Yamamoto
Bankai and it's multiple forms Each of
which could be a Bankai on its own
what's astounding is how Yamamoto looks
100% terrifying it's as if he didn't
even need it anyway this bang guy isn't
just physically powered it's also a
mentor drain imagine facing off against
his Powerhouse with him constantly
switching between his four stances the
anime team flexs their animation skills
demonstrating their Mastery of impactful
frames a package like this is the
perfect stage for Yamamoto to shine
brilliantly before exiting the
scene now we've reached the end of the
video and we hope you enjoyed it as much
as we did making it if you've got any
suggestions for entries you wish we'd
covered then head on down to our comment
section and let us know what you think
as always don't forget to like subscribe
and click the notifications for more
thrilling anime moments like these see
you in the next one